i can't have jessica and robin here
without talking a little pussycat dolls
um as a loyal fan myself i have to tell
you
react was a highlight of 2020.
[Music]
so what is the current status of the
group
well you know okay so as of right now we
are all
very much together we've just been
staying
in touch you know every day staying with
each other
holding on to each other as hard as we
can but we
can't give a specific date because we
don't
you know it's like we'd be making it up
if we were giving
the actual data when we're going back
out on the road but
what i do know is the fact that the
dolls are all together
we are not going anywhere we all want
we all are going to move forward into
the next phase of the reunion that's a
fact and we're all so excited
we love each other we have such a great
relationship and we can't wait to tour
the world again together
okay so confirmed touring
can you oh for sure can you confirm an
album on the way
it's in the works yes it's in the works
we will definitely have new music
for sure i mean it's it's inevitable
because all the girls are
true artists all the girls are true
singers and and
and you know incredibly
hot talented me obviously our hits
are our gigantic hits and of course
we're going to be doing those
but we always have to add we're going to
be adding new music and that's already
it's already in the works
okay well that's reassuring because you
you guys delivered
such fire when you gave us react and
then a lot of pussycat doll fans are are
talking online and they're just curious
why was a follow-up single not released
in 2020
well it was a pandemic you know
everything kind of apart we're you know
some of the girls live in the uk
and most of us live in the us so it's
like in the safety of everyone getting
together
ashley and and kim live in the uk
um nicole is back and forth uh from here
to in the in
in to the uk and uh and then you know
jessica um and carmite are here and i'm
here
so it is just more challenging to be to
just go into the studio and just
start recording and yet we are working
it out you know what i mean if we waited
this long to be able to do a reunion we
it's okay we can wait this long to come
out with more music we're grateful to
you for always delivering i mean
you were gracious enough to tell e.t the
exclusive that you're expecting your
first baby jessica
i'm hoping that we can continue riding
the exclusive train
is there anything that you can tell us
that will get the fans really really
excited
i think you're gonna hear a lot of us
you know yes
a lot about singing all the other girls
you know
all my all my band mates are incredibly
talented they have beautiful voices
and i think it's definitely time for
them to shine there's so many artists
that we would love to collaborate with
you know it's like every day everyone's
like
you know they want you know they they
are the fans always have their ideas
like i've been working with carol g and
everyone's like characters
and then we also love like people like
cardi b and like meg stallion
italian i'd love to even do another
collab with snoop
because i love me some snoop pcd on me
yeah i thought i saw a pussycat
the fans can't quite seem to ever get
enough pussycat dolls
how long do you see this iteration of
the band going for i'm down to do it so
i'm eighty-five
i'm saying yeah all right i mean you
know i think
as long as we can do it you know the
fans want it we want to give them what
they
want if it wasn't for the fans we would
not be who we are today and we love them
so so much
[Music]
i've never seen a group of girls work so
incredibly hard that i feel that that
energy
is going to be brought into this next
phase
which is hopefully coming up really soon
you know we're here we're here and we're
here to stay
and we just have to wait for jessica to
have her baby
and that is a that is a good point robin
i mean jessica once you have the little
one
are you planning to bring him out on the
road with you i am for sure i'm going to
hire a nurse and she's going to come on
the road with me
and we're just going to do it you know
i want to ask you i spoke with melody
last year
about the record that she put out i'm
really focused on
this project i want to give space for
myself i want to give space for the
girls
they're releasing new music i think you
know i need my space and they need
theirs
not in a negative way just yeah just
being able to grow
yes yeah yeah absolutely yes absolutely
what has it been like not having her
there with you on stage
i gotta say i miss her i'm gonna cry um
i
i you know i respect her decision um and
i think she's an incredible artist
uh but i we had a psychic tell us a long
time ago that we had a past
life together so i have a connection to
melody that is just
unbelievable and i love her i miss her i
wish she'd come back
to be honest with you i'm gonna chris
this is hormones
but um you know there's no bad blood we
just we adore her
the first time i saw her she was a child
and i remember saying like i just found
a girl
she's like christina aguilera yet she's
so unique i've never seen any girl like
her
she wanted to go and she wanted to move
forward into her solo and
and be be her own do her own thing which
we all
respect but certainly all support her so
much
yeah jessica i see you getting very
emotional do you want to look in the
camera and say
any message you have for melody oh my
god
i love you mel you know that and you you
know you're an auntie
um and i just i'm so grateful for our
friendship and um
come back if you want yes we always say
that the door is the door is always
there
the door is always wide open for melody
and she knows that
can you give an update on other than
pussycat dolls
which groups are you currently involved
with or developing
with next generation um you know we had
started it
and and pia mia came in and pia is a
very good friend of mine who i also am a
creative director
on her project with mikey and um
he had you know really at the end of the
day wanted to just continue her solo
career so we kind of we kind of just
separated
the two and i am still very close with
the girls
from net would call next-gen and you
know
it really what happened was the reunion
just kind of like
came in like like a like a like a s
a bullet just came in and went like wait
i'm here the reunion is here and we're
ready to go
and so i had to stop everything that i
was doing
to really focus on the reunion and i'm
also working on something for vegas
inspired by from the early days of the
pussycat dolls
which would mean bringing in different
celebrities and different
a lot you know and all obviously the ogs
but i'm bringing it to another level
that's going to be so like just
outrageous it's girls from all over the
world that like i want to be able to
bring in
and talent and always have i love i'm
the kind of person that i always want to
give that platform to and i i applaud
you for always prioritizing women
but you know we have to recognize it's
been i believe 15
16 years since jessica the the group
first
launched and i think as both of you
ladies well know we're in a very
different place in the world with
how we view women how we now empower
women even more so i know robin you
always have
um but i'm talking about in society as
you know as a general
um you know the way we celebrate women's
bodies and we we celebrate
all shapes and sizes and colors what to
you
um is most different about pcd today
versus what you were experiencing in you
know 2005
2006. i have to say that
ever since i got into the pussycats also
being voluptuous and
having curves was embraced and
celebrated in the pussycat dolls it was
very womanly you don't have to be stick
skinny to be beautiful and that's what i
always appreciated with [ __ ] kettles i
remember like
back in the day before we got the record
deal the girls were eating mcdonald's
and it was like it was you know chicken
nuggets it was like oh my god it's like
we're not watching or we we are women
this is it and it's okay to have a
little bit of meat on you and now
even more than ever it definitely has
changed and
like obviously you know the kardashians
are a big part of that and look at lizzo
and celeb
um your bodies and saying you know what
this is this is what i personally have
always said like
be the best version of yourself and i
try to really instill that and inspire
people you know with that because i love
all these different kinds of bodies
it was definitely a different world back
then i think women weren't as celebrated
it was a very misogynistic world back
then
yeah um women were pinned against each
other you know they always wanted to see
it there was cat fights between us and
instead of raising each other up and
being the queens that we are
you know i mean it was like always like
oh they hate each other or this and that
and it's just ridiculous
um so i'm grateful for that time to
change we are
celebrating women there's a reason that
gwen stefani charlize theron
scarlett johansson fergie paris hilton
kim kardashian there's a reason that all
of these amazing women
wanted to be a part of it because they
wanted to celebrate themselves
as women that was maybe something that
they weren't able to do out there
on stage or as an in an acting role that
is timeless
and that's why i'm continuing to work on
more than the reunion you know more than
that with the pussycat dolls brand